El lunes por la mañana había
12 pulgadas de nieve sobre el suelo.
La temperatura subió y para el martes en la mañana se habían derretido 2 pulgadas.
2 pulgadas más se derritieron para el
miércoles de la mañana.
Este patrón continuó durante toda la semana hasta que la nieve desapareció.
básicamente no están diciendo que el lunes en la mañana había 12 pulgadas de nieve,
y cada día se fueron perdiendo 2 pulgadas.
El martes había 10 pulgadas, el miércoles había 8 pulgadas y este patrón continuó.
Y lo que nos piden es,
elabora una ecuación y una gráfica...
que muestre la relación entre el día
y la cantidad de nieve sobre el suelo.
Definamos entonces una variable que nos indique ¿cuántos días han pasado desde el lunes?
así que "sea"
"sea" "x" igual a días...
después... días después del lunes
y "sea" "y"...
"sea" "y" igual
a pulgadas...
pulgadas de nieve sobre el suelo
pulgadas de nieve sobre el suelo,
una manera de ver esto es...
"y" el número de pulgadas de nieve
va a ser, el primer día,
tuvimos 12 pulgadas
cuando "x" era igual a 0,
lunes había 12 pulgadas
y cada día se pierden 2 pulgadas,
es decir, hay que restarle 2 por el número de días
así el martes ha pasado un día,
entonces hay
12 menos 2 por 1 = 10 pulgadas
el miércoles han pasado 2 días,
hay 12 menos 2 por 2 = 8 pulgadas
y así sucesivamente...
Así es que esta es la ecuación que relaciona el número de pulgadas de nieve con el número de días
"x" es el número de días que han
transcurrido después del lunes
y "y" es el número de pulgadas
de nieve sobre el suelo.
Empezamos con 12 y cada día se derritieron exactamente 2 pulgadas.
Ahora grafiquemos esta ecuación
construyamos nuestros ejes,
este es mi eje vertical, mi eje "y",
que son pulgadas,
"y" es igual a pulgadas de nieve,
pongamos "y" igual a pulgadas nieve
mientras que "x"
el eje "x"...
déjame bajar un poco...
el eje "x"
representa días
días después del lunes...
días después lunes,
aquí tendríamos 0 días
aquí tendríamos
1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6 días después del lunes
y a los 0 días después del lunes,
es decir, el mero lunes
teníamos 12 pulgadas de nieve
sobre el suelo
vamos a ponerlo por aquí,
este punto indica 12 pulgadas de nieve
sobre el suelo el lunes
de hecho, hagamos una tabla para que sea más fácil graficar los puntos
entonces tenemos nuestra tabla,
estos son los valores de "x" y de "y"
"x" el número de días, esos serían,
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 días después del lunes,
ahora para "y" empezamos con 12 pulgadas,
el día 0 el mero lunes tenemos 12 pulgadas,
y perdemos 2 pulgadas cada día
el martes ya hay 10,
luego 8, 6, 4, 2 y 0
grafiquemos los puntos
ya hemos graficado el 0, 12
grafiquemos ahora el 1,10...
lo voy a hacer con otro color...
el 1,10 aquí tenemos el 10 para la "y",
este seria el punto 1, 10
luego el punto 2, 8
el punto 2, aquí tenemos el 2,
aquí tendríamos el 8 para la "y"
este es el 8 para la "y"
luego tenemos el punto 3, 6...
el punto 3, 6...
aquí ubicamos el punto 3, 6
3 para la "x",
6 para la "y",
observamos que
ya podemos ver a través de estos puntos
cómo se está formando una recta,
posteriormente tenemos el punto 4, 4
en el día 4 tenemos
4 pulgadas de nieve sobre el suelo
tenemos aquí entonces el punto 4, 4
luego el punto 5, 2...
5, 2,
lo tenemos aquí
este es el 2 para la "y"
y finalmente 6 días
después del lunes, es decir, el domingo
ya no hay nieve sobre el piso,
ubicamos entonces el punto 6, 0
y podemos ver así la línea que se forma
representando a la ecuación,
que es una relación lineal
quedó un poco curva
por como puse los puntos
pero es en realidad una línea recta
ya hemos hecho lo que nos pedían
una ecuación que refleja que al principio había 12 pulgadas de nieve y se perdían 2 pulgadas cada día
y también construimos la gráfica de la ecuación.